what is this thing
haven't you ever seen them oh we were
hot Airy going yeah things went right
okay
I see it now what's going on there
Walter
it's been forever since kind of regular
seats
feels good to be back behind the camera
behind the scenes yes yeah in front of
the scenes behind the scenes they doing
the chart thing again
do you remember Jim which Albert ooh the
Chipmunks is this together yeah you know
there were something working huh he's
like oh I didn't know that Jason leaves
I was about to say why Jason
yeah it's like I get that okay I can see
a little bit yes but Jason Lee used to
be pretty cool all girls Joanie's
stuffed Batman like this is mine
yes women in teens will watch anything
so we could say oh I know I am when I
see a cat video
oh yeah yesterday my best friend can
copy one of the cancer City okay I keep
that kid at your face oh can you three
yeah it's good it's good it's not weird
but uh can you kind of hang your heads
down a little bit like that and then
yeah with the camera pants down to you
thank you sort of till your heads up so
as soon as they say you know he says oh
is they move by the way yeah you three
can come on oh yeah okay directly at the
camera so all right I see you two in
frame here so as soon as I say action
that's what you doin comin all right
quiet on the set you all right should we
say yes together is it Justin see uh I
likey I'm just going yes yes and action
yes ah where am I looking
all right the camera you're both already
ready yep and action
yes ah with the movie making nut loads
of money at the box office we have
submitted ourselves as the only real
Chipmunks franchise but who's even
watching these movies are so stupid I
have a bunch of lines in this line and
then I started going around to Malcolm
saying his line simple a demographic
that never lets us down be all girls be
all girls women in teens who will watch
anything just to say oh oh you got yeah
I want a from your line so all right so
you're already a all right and action
women in teens will watch anything
simply just to say
sarah lowther Facebook
Ella great we'll try it out from the
beginning
it's like hyper all dressed up yeah
enough of that
yeah okay that's good yeah that was a
good uh I see it be a little bit more
undecided Duggars Tina you know just how
like you know with the QC just hey you
know come on just a little bit more a
champagne a little bit more high school
adjust you know shut up we're trying to
do this like all right guys are not cool
you know yeah yeah I'm not that not not
quite mean it's a little bit more like
just you know just who's dropping 50
points this plus turd uh to end on your
line with the balloon Tate just a hand
faster but the delivery was pretty good
okay everybody ready go in the set and
action damn it your love for cuteness is
ruining a perfectly good franchise but
they're just so adorable
we're not here to analyze story you just
want to look at cute little animals do
cute little things oh I just want to
pitch their sheep no you ladies are
sucking up the dignity of a great
adventure series oh really
it's in your movie about Chipmunks who
operate balloons for diamond smuggling
it made a lot of sense in the eighties
more than Eleanor not wearing green
hey I'm colorblind okay well me too
enough of that
great that was wonderful uh we'll go
ahead look at the next bit here
yeah now Walters got the camera Oh No
yes what it means is work yeah like that
okay
is it possible like that to jump your
head forward a bit
that was great that was right okay you
can do that yes it's on there I can show
you the world shining sherry when
display good I like do the sweet
good
can you see off back here yeah okay
I can totally see Jim yes how about me
no I can't see you okay I can hold this
hey I just wanna wake Lea gets it set up
cuz when GI moves forward it's going to
shift this so whenever she's in position
that I'm yeah it's okay he'll jump on
screen okay oh yeah for real yeah lean
one more damn I'm serving is it possible
to with the whole thing this way now
this is tight a pencil yes Karen why we
can hold it that way
wait wait I think it's okay yes the
payrolls are awesome damn early again
the pills the perils I think that work
yeah don't keep doing this cool cool and
yeah I think I'm shaking just every
every line is what you sort of doing you
know
you know like that yeah I think on that
when you're paddling like dead don't do
that as much because it's funny for
really looks like you're leaning out so
yeah really yeah I mean the more of a
contrast you can have to your body
shooting out with your arms back like
that yes but you can still sort of jump
it out like so okay yeah yeah okay sorry
you're safe okay are you ready John yeah
will you say it's just like like is it
yeah okay so it's a go do all crossover
with the Smurfs you know with the real
Chipmunks movie okay all right you all
right yeah yeah chance to return to
Brooklyn yeah laughing no answer that
there's a little big here go forward a
bit is it all right now the big thing is
can you cuz we should she's doing it so
we still get more looks oh yeah yeah
oh no come on um please at the dance you
guys are gonna do yeah oh I'm just
trying to get feeling back into my oh
that's a good way cool oh nice Emily
Riverdance latin-american alright guys
we had this record that would keep
playing you know what's really for jump
over to pick it up over to pick what you
Department yeah see what she closet just
you used to do constant level clogging
in high school we had to cover a river
dance song and every time it would come
on saige Rachel maybe like Riverdance
I'll say - Rachel and I would just go by
her sponsor yeah
rainy Walter yeah
good yeah okay camera how to issue the
robot Ahmad just looks lat yes good
shimmy-shimmy knows all right oh yeah
there you go good I'm high as a look rub
its so why it's so large
yeah you dug
good
oh yeah of the shot run really matter
Eddie it's a words for the other ones
Salil irresolute and elder and lots of
licking goddamn ass you said let me
double-check
I'm pretty sure not don't go too far up
the wall all right I know what it is I
know yeah what you do you're gonna be
facing this way header that way you're
going to be holding on to these just
serve going like that cuz thats weird i
doing a shot before it there you go yeah
are we smiling
uh no you're just looking yeah oh my
gosh pigtails bow so much oh yeah my
pony puzzle toilet keying and that's
good tricky sorry Phil you just elected
so much money I'll be your background
audio really see what the enemy doesn't
show gotcha
girls girls sweat shimmer
go group Barca like my life vampire
okay um alright so it so it's gonna be
um no yeah with a real chipmunk movie
do you even know how torture bugs
oh yeah and then be sure turn your head
all the way that way isn't it Jim monks
uh yeah there you go
and there close the eyes to it oh yeah
perfect perfect okay
oh you're just going back and forth heal
together correctly perfect okay how are
you are you gonna have they are strong
men oh boy
so unless the only thing I can see here
the green screen hot-air balloon
rotation we got never doing this the
dumb way maybe Walter should be closer
to up here yeah that's true what I like
right here yeah yeah cuz you're fine
doing when I've seen yours just being a
little bit of Walter Tammy we want be
like bloody have like here that'll work
yeah or you could um this is okay so
what uh so how let's try this can you
guys try spinning it as fast as you can
and that's a snapchat yes you're all do
the monkey turn it back a little bit yes
okay here we go okay with that okay so
this is some right after go do all
across over with this first that's what
goes do get where the wheel Jimbo's
movie he and by the time he gets to be a
chuckles movie the end of that chamber
should be in front okay so the way
you're spinning before that was that was
pretty good so are we seeking mill chips
movie yeah movie if I right after go to
all trust Oh over with I think I'm with
you should start turning over with the
smirks it like on with you should start
turning it
haha
well they made it even if that fell that
looks gorgeous
it was wonderful kinky no Danny I'm one
more yeah all right now dog yeah
what even if it fell front it look door
I told you I warned them all I did
structurally speaking it's not sound
this is disaster epic proportions
waiting man we got it you got it you
look really good yes yeah she's my lover
Torquay one of them's gonna have to hold
on to it are you holding up 4k here
timber come here for a second Oh
stand right there yeah she's tall enough
to ride you know I - maybe
this requires me to spend
spandy feels good like I mean doesn't
that she said look petite SNP though
that's not taking it so we could just
make sure it's taller than did you turn
it off it's very Marilyn Monroe but no -
here - yeah this with a bigger plan and
yes it's part of the character see how
she's socially see well you know let's
see how listen to get me a favor game
what you do like a low angle shot maybe
my saying that now so angle me okay
she's a little too tall now but you're
right the low angle might make it look
okay let's see if they move in more is
that a problem
yes just really back and forth like that
just really beat the shit out of that
fucking woman okay is it possible you're
right and I can see the bottom so you're
right now yeah now the first one you do
immediately yeah more shoulders yeah but
see you can soon
oh go ahead try it
dress yourself because yours just has
the stable really careful yeah
so I move my head yeah I think that way
okay all right I think we're good right
ready for Noah yeah
just do the Michael Johnny
oh stop dancing so Rob's going to be
this guy the statues that you're looking
behind in this are actually the statues
of these characters oh really
so and like in both these shots two
characters are imitating the statute
clearly Oh what you're going to be doing
but this is going to be the statute oh
that's the guy you're going to lean
behind but then you're going to imitate
him so what will get you robbed shot
first but after that you're going to ads
like you're coming in from behind the
statue going he just can't like that I
think it all your mouth a little more
overly yeah there you go
yeah and I'm Ross just kind of trying to
make it in the day the other guy so yeah
that will be good looking from the yeah
you're gonna be coming from way too
selfish okay I'm gonna do I think you
can just do that and skin free clothes
great on this one just be safe at the
face
Fishkin
and this explosion is exact result of it
your father
what's great okay let's get it out
Malcolm oh yeah such a weird place yeah
just look at those lip of those chompers
well are you're going to have your head
actually turn this way almost to the
camera like here your heads turn just a
little bit maybe like looking at that
blind next to the line Onix our way yeah
and but you're going to have your eye
and should go back to where you were
before okay like rope right there that's
free to the center get over there down
about there that should be good give
your mouse going to you about level yes
I'm still facing good
let's say okay let's mention statue for
you here you're peeking behind it I like
to look at the door
so far go look at the green screen up
don't snow but estimation so you guys
are falling downstairs come on you don't
meet people shit here haha this is the
most public yet about many humiliations
welcome here later that heart and charts
really mean that's good okay
okay so let's say
it's the curse of arms my heart belongs
to your numbers are attracted yes I hear
that at some point it may be coming down
there's all good points out but at some
point it hasn't gone
you gotta crank it down okay okay
so yes I'm wrapping this chart off you
know pretty much like right here and you
just write and then you're both just
gonna do a good job that's it so
people's skin kind of yeah like you're
already both gonna be falling backwards
I want a little bit of the lean back any
could get closer about so let's just go
get a job over here
I make your post I talk oh yes good yeah
so that's why I'm like that okay so
here's my plan
hahaha perfect we could only go for
about there's my ganache up for you so
it's okay if you go into what well let
me
okay so backwards and yeah and then just
had to the sound like I just wail your
arms
try not to lopsided as you me all right
when I get hit which way is my face
which way is your Facebook where does he
get cast initially the original right to
let
oh and when you get hit he sort of
standard for a second unfolds backwards
okay so I got bit on the right cheek oh
I see
I think it's the other one thinking look
it's not cheap yeah which cheek okay all
right y'all ready
I know it's just we're not I don't I
would rather take this stump crap fall
down the stairs so late no although the
point that it's so that face my life
what sector like that fine till I laugh
uh yeah
difficult okay and go ahead and lean
forward a little bit rough ready yep and
actually
I want to do take the octopus wih wrap
it around it look great space it's like
okay okay beautiful beautiful I thought
my invite we should hit your head a
chart cross
good alright then this one will do the
flash in there so we'll have you come up
I'll say a flash you get yourself in the
open face and I'll say action of any
plan okay
your hats covering a little bit of your
eyes so clean your head up a little bit
there you go ready and action
flash
good looking good you're kicked in the
face face it's good I die for my charts
charts of my life and that is I end
other chart references the fine thing is
I accepted your SIA they have them
flailing on the ground there I was like
well how do I do that bumping into
Michael Bay you know like have me get in
there and stuff I realized oh just
explode yes happen to be in Michael
Bay's kaboom it's for this what no one's
hit him yet the charts say is movies
just have insane budgets because of all
the explosions what everybody says this
movie's blow is like no he'll blow keep
we're just all we have to just wear you
can time it and that's not the end
little yet so what is it I mean we start
off ya know 5 6
yeah I mean the Wiggles like wiggle
wiggle wiggle wiggle
uh-huh 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 good
y'all ready up rolling 5 6 7 8 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8
yeah
we are saved by the bell hi it's Lily
you guys are noticing save about
can we do one more
ready
action
okay